good morning John your new book The
Fault in Our Stars has aside from being
totally gripping and touching and
hilarious and genius which no one knows
yet because I've read it but they
haven't has become something of a the
sensation like I don't know if you know
this but I don't think that anyone has
ever done what you just did and of
course when I say you I mean us all
including me because I helped I made
half of our 875 videos and more than me
the people who watch the videos have
helped thank you yeah number one on the
Amazon and Barnes & Noble bestseller
charts four days running with like no
Blissett II at all and of this store it
was just written up in the freaking Wall
Street Journal and John the people who
read The Wall Street Journal are like
very important these are people who
could seriously impact like your future
career and those people are probably
coming right now from The Wall Street
Journal article to check out the floor
but this and see what this is all about
so how's your brother gonna make sure
that we put our best foot forward for
those people so that you have the
maximum opportunity to get
[Music]
or The Wall Street Journal's you was
gone yet and that was a very punishing
punishment although because Jeff Bezos
the guy who came around with me to film
all of this cuz I was pretty sure
Katherine wouldn't want to do it I don't
know as a punishment and he was like I
think now that you have told me that it
is a punishment I'm going to make sure
that it is punishing like the one in
front of the restaurant with me humping
the drunk people sign that was a very
long shot the song that you heard during
that is a karaoke track from a song from
Ellen Hardcastle called shake a booty
and that was produced by the magnificent
Luke Conard who you probably probably
knew that just by listening to it is my
first damn song and I'm really excited
to let you have the full version
eventually Bing of which pre-orders
through Ellen Hardcastle begin never
John's book has a very long pre-order
time in my album has no pre-order we've
decided though that's different for me
John I really do want to congratulate
you on the the pre success of The Fault
in Our Stars it deserves it it's gonna
be a pretty big deal I think thank you
so much to the nerdfighters for making
this a huge huge freakin deal being a
part of something that I think is pretty
historical in the and the timeline of
the publishing industry that's gonna be
amazing all the success even the Wall
Street Journal article is very well
deserved John I'll see you on Monday
it's up meet you is it okay if I hump
your car
[Music]